[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
throughout that far
[Music]
Damon we've been together on shark tank
forever what have you learned now after
spending ten years on the show what's
different now what's changed for you the
quality of the deals are much different
they are much better the quality of the
deal that they give the casting agents
the word casting agents in the beginning
didn't know you know what a good deal
was or good business was and because
they were casting in somebody would say
to them you know I'm doing a million I'm
doing a thirty million dollar business I
got one employee they didn't realize if
they should say are you selling crack or
are you selling heroin but now they know
the bet the deal flow is better so
because I'm after sitting and watching
all of us debate these deals over the
last couple of years they think they
bring a better quality also you know I
don't even think Instagram was out when
Shark Tank first started and now you
have social media to conversion so we
know how to test the deals and and and
those people know how to actually sell
without being dependent on retail I
think they know us much better than we
know who then went well well they know
us period we don't know them so they
know how to push in our buttons and some
of these people were 10 years old when
starting for starter now they're you
know somebody who was a social-media
influencer and they grew up knowing
about royalties and clawbacks and
mezzanine financing and all that subdue
to us and now they're this way more
articulate women income [ __ ] when I
teach art they become such a monster
class I think as people started to
realize I think first two or three
seasons people who didn't know what it
was well you in the shark in the tank of
sharks who gets the money when do they
win and what's the game you know all
this up and you know due to you know
eight people 10 people 20 people a year
going out and saying you know I really
got the money and here's my business and
then going on separate platforms I think
the tentacles of the show started to
reach out this you know people sort of
realized that you know I could sit here
on my couch and talk crap I want about
how I want to be rich and famous at the
end or do something and this person on
this tree
was doing the same thing and they got
out and they busted their ass and then
they got out there and did it so I have
no excuse and also I think people
started to realize that they watch the
show their family and say now I know how
to negotiate to get what I want whether
it's getting the remote control away
from my my significant other or whether
it's getting a raise I getting some
funding and I think that it was just so
informative that people were smarter the
water cooler on Monday morning and
sharing the information it kind of went
viral before or viral was viral you know
what pisses you off the most from
someone pitching what is the one thing
that drives you nuts when you're sitting
there because you know I have my own
opinion too but what drives you crazy
[ __ ] I'd be crazy as somebody with
their hat in their hand they're asking
for they have two million dollars in the
bank already and they already have
funding by various amount of people and
they're asking us for more money I
believe that they're exploiting the
platform to exploiting the people
they're taking the the chance away from
another family who probably risked it
all for five years at RIT and and now
they only have one last chance as to see
the sharks and we can only see only a
certain amount of people so I think
they're greedy selfish bastards the
truth and especially when they're doing
that I think even if they don't get a
deal they already got funny and they're
looking for a commercial even if they
don't get a deal and I just think
there's I think there's savages and just
nasty people they remind me of you beef
is your big beef there as they took a
slot away from somebody that could have
really used the dough but they yeah we
wouldn't call those gold diggers right
that gold I'm told is [ __ ] you know
yeah all right listen we got a lot of
questions to get to but before before we
start answering because I've got some
doozies for you know these come from all
around the world and so you're gonna be
answering some of these questions I got
a book here right these things called
Daymond John power ship
this is shameless promotion
Shadis promotion yes okay by the best
why why should I even help you sell one
more of these I don't get anything out
of it I'm not getting a royalty out of
this deal but here I am helping you sell
another one these books what is this
book number eighteen from you yeah this
is No
five and it already is a national
bestseller why should you sell why
should you push the book because you no
matter how nasty and you are you act at
the end of the day you know you want to
help other entrepreneurs in that book
helps entrepreneurs and this tough time
we're in right now the reason I want to
read this book is I'm going to get
examples of people have actually taken
some adversity and turned it into
something amazing building up their own
plant shops that's not example is a very
successful entrepreneurs that's exactly
it but I also show you how to negotiate
because it's not about negotiation when
you see Kevin Damon or shark tank is
about what influence have you built
fryer it's how you negotiate in the best
interest for the person on the other
side of table and how you nourish your
relationship afterwards I give
everything from sigh body language in
their negotiation tips to mental
negotiation tips so that's what the book
is about how do you change your strategy
for marketing this statement because
just before you launch this you usually
do a book unit a book tour I go to these
things I got my sign copy here that's
cool look at this sign my name is John
that means I can put on ebay maybe make
five bucks really excited but at the end
of the day you didn't get to do that
here what strategy did you use to get
this out there's no number one selling
yeah exactly so I had to polish of
myself normally you go to a bunch of
books or xeno and you do these tours
with these thousands of people in arenas
or in your speaking engagements you tell
them that I will stay an extra hour
longer if you buy 500 bucks and I'll
sign or take this is everybody else but
now I've had to adjust do way more
podcast I've had to do way more
streaming platform digital book signings
where I'm signing it right now and you
know your your digitally there and you
ask me what to put in the book and I
have to do that for five hours at a time
you know this happened to me you know
believe in my food we'll put out an
album which was a compilation of known
artists and brand new artists back in
2001 and when I put out that out myself
three million dollar album and when I
put out that out the day I put it out
nine eleven it just happened so I'm used
to putting out things when the world is
looking for their on the news of their
nesting so I was kind of used to this
already and I think that's why the books
still made it to you know the top of the
national
because I've been virtually shifting the
same way I'm something interesting let's
get to the questions cuz I got a ton of
them here you ready yeah so here we go
this one's from Thomas Patton
first off let me tell you I'm a huge fan
so keep up the great work I know you are
a pretty big watch guy and I would like
to know what your opinion is on what the
effect will be on the resale of the
luxury watch market particularly
high-end watches we've seen companies
like Patek and armor spur get sold their
resale value do you think this will
continue with what's going on so Thomas
is asking but you love watches you're
always wearing a nice piece on your
wrist I love watches what's gonna happen
after this Damon you know I would have
to really tell me you're real I mean I
like watches you are you love excessive
walks I don't actually want I first
bought my first million dollars worth of
the watch behind sold and back I think
that I did it the dlg made more money
thousands on them so wrong piece it is
maybe them counterfeit and yes you know
I would have encrust out like what am i
fat boletes encrusted out with a lot of
diamonds but they're not Patek Phillipe
diamonds they're who keeps diamonds so I
ruined the watch so I don't know I'm
gonna ask you about what do you think
about that the marks get a little bounce
back or not I think it's gonna get
really interesting because right now I'm
very I work with a lot of different
makers and and maisons as they call them
most of the watchmakers that are the
most valuable on earth like an AP or a
Rolex or Patek watchmaker or SPG or and
watchmaker there are over 60 years old
so they are they are now quarantined up
in the mountains they're not going into
Geneva they're not even going near Paris
and not going anywhere they're not
working there is no production going on
of any Rolexes for example the most you
know coveted watch on earth you could
argue so if someone said to you you
could get a rainbow Rolex Daytona right
now a brand new one in a box would it be
worth more than it was twelve weeks ago
or less I'd argue more because people
really covet those watches and certain
people that love that stuff like to have
it
let's think about another way what if
the market drives up and there's not a
lot of available ones out there and
unbuckling people are passing and or
they need to raise capital don't you
think there may be a flood of inventory
out there and not enough buyers you're
absolutely right that's the whole
concept of supply and demand but you can
look at the price every hour of every
watch an AP a Rolex you know Jake -
Jordan what FP Jordan you can check that
by the hour all around the world and
prices have not corrected yet in fact
some have gone up so Damon I'm actually
shooting a piece on watches as an asset
class right now and I've got some of
these watches that Thomas is talking
about I mean I don't know why we just
don't settle this debate right now let's
have a look at them and then we'll just
go right online and see what the
mark-to-market prices that might be the
easiest thing to do
let me grab him I mean I know he's
talking about AP and and protect
Phillipe so you know I've got him here
so here's a here's an AP jumbo very
desirable watch here's a Patek Phillipe
5711 1a the blue face very desirable
here is a you know blinged out as you
said earlier this is a blinged out Rolex
this is a rose rainbow very rare watch
but you know I know people are going to
criticize by basically saying well you
know you're you're only picking really
exclusive watches but what's the
difference between this and picking
stocks I mean if you're an investor
you're picking stocks you think are
great if you're an investor in watches
as an asset class you're picking watches
that you think you're great I think
these are great watches to invest in so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to use
an app called chrono 24 and go look at
the actual spot prices and just on a
percentage basis to see how these things
have gone up or down this is spot
pricing like as of last night so you
know I don't know it's not going to be
easy to argue so let's just let's look
at these watches okay let's start with
let's start with a Patek Phillipe 57
eleven Thomas talked about that or patek
anyways is this a good investment or not
I'm talking about if you bought it at
retail and held on to it it has
appreciated it 116 percent yeah I think
that's a pretty good investment all
right let's go to jumbo ap it's a nice
watch
I've tricked it out with a red band so I
can wear it on television let's go check
that out let's look at what a jumbo is
trading for right now and so how'd you
bought the jumbo at retail you're up 70%
that's pretty good now let's now this by
the way Daymond this is uh this is not
Pookie's diamonds buddy
this is Rolex jewelers making this watch
that's what makes it desirable so let's
see how that one has done a rainbow
Daytona rose gold and the answer is
let's see yeah okay this little puppy is
up one hundred and forty-one percent I
rest my case your honor now I'm not
telling people to buy these watches I
mean given the environment out there I
think it's a good idea to keep your
powder dry but watches as an asset class
is what I'm talking about this is done
way better than the stock market there's
no there's no question so III think it's
like rare art I mean that's the way to
look at it and you know and I think that
certain pieces and just like you have to
be you have to be very selective in art
and have to be very selective in stocks
and bonds you have to be very selective
and watches but the fun thing about
these is they're great to wear and you
hold on to them and they appreciated
value that's a really little sweetie but
you know that's my point
I think we've answered Thomas's question
we did a lot of work on it actually but
those of you are watch lovers we learn
together every day let's move on first
thing
money immediately over to me at Celtic
Thunder calm and I will put that money
to work David
Damon decided to rebrand himself this
year chocolate thunder yeah I don't get
it either but I was there at the moment
it happened on the Shark Tank side watch
this this is Gracie stuff marki please
excuse me chocolate thunder said he
would like to walk one two set what is
this
where's the light at we have a light
lightning ready everything's ready this
chocolate thunder says what is that
chuckles understood your hands on your
head put your feet on you
I feel a hater somewhere why yes it is
Oh chucka thunder we may proceed dumbest
[ __ ] I've ever seen chocolate
you can't believe how poor you get nice
spread $40 this is what happens I'm
ready
here's the question from Brock I wanted
to know your opinion on the franchises
things such as risk and if it's a good
investment
I've actually purchased through
restaurant franchises with my brother
and we went 50-50 on them I believe a
restaurant concepts got lots of
potential in our area we're using most
of our artists pursue this so I would
appreciate me summarize that one for
your Damon it's Brock and his brother
took their inheritance in invested in
two different restaurant franchises
that's got to be tough because we know
what's happening the restaurant business
now but what do you think generally
speaking about becoming a franchisee
where's your head at on that I like the
franchise model I think that if you know
you want to learn off of the Kevin
O'Leary in the Damon's out in the world
who bust their ass and figured out how
to make this thing work if it's the
franchise model I know listen you go
down friends I know well maybe they have
a Papa John's franchise right now and
pieces going through the roof right so I
like that because they've already
figured out what to do and you don't
have to figure out what you do uses out
and figure out how to do the best at
what you're doing as well as that give
you the tools and everything else to
maybe go ahead and extend and open other
products I really do like franchise idea
uh only franchise that I say you stay
away from the ones that are 24 hours
that's the biggest challenge the 24 hour
you make the bulk of your money during
the day and then you eat into your
profits at night generally but I like
friends I like franchise plus you have
to snap 24 hours that's not easy to do
you got to be resolved
in a bad at the same time exactly
there's another question in there Damon
I want to hear you out on he's saying
he's a party with his brother we're yeah
and investing with family members yes or
knowing that I rather not however even
if you do I think prior to anything you
gotta pull up the right structure and
make sure you have the right structure I
think the structure should be of course
they can't be 50/50 because then you got
their tithe a little hurt you so
everybody needs to know their job and
just like a stranger I get sixty percent
you get forty percent you handle finance
I handle distribution and we have a
tiebreaker with this person that person
but the whole lovey lovey lovey you know
happy thing it probably never works out
you know when your brothers are sibling
or even best friends be very careful
business still business and what if one
of you just get ran over by a bus one of
what if one of you find a great uh
significant other and decides to leave
and go to Bali it you know carve canoes
you know who's going to run the business
and how is the structure gonna work so
you have to have a structure in place
problem is you can't fire your mother or
you can but then it's a really tough
Sunday night dinner yeah all right let's
get to another question here this one's
from Emma alright Emma what do you got
I missed a wonderful I'm planning a very
small holiday dinner this weekend and I
want to cook most the holiday yeah it's
Easter I want to cook a honeyed ham and
a small turkey I thought I'd like to try
deconstructing the turkey what do you
know about that well Emma you've come to
the right place
chef wonderful knows everything about
deconstructing turkey and it's a very
controversial topic right now montz the
chef community but first I have to
invoke him how do I get chef wonderful
it's very easy you snap your fingers
twice and you say welcome Emma did
someone call chef wonderful to the
rescue
look I'll walk you through the whole
thing Emma it's that time of the year
again chef wonderful outside why I'm
about to go purchase the turkey for the
big holiday dinner when you cook a bird
the leg and the breasts cook at
different times so if you try to just
cook for
it cooks faster than the breasts and the
breast is undercooked
if you cook for the breast the leg is
tough and dried out there is a way to
solve this problem that's called
deconstructing the road which you're
going to do right now first the first
things first you got to separate the
wings from the legs right off the main
body rule Allah look how fast this is
happening it doesn't take a long time
beautiful look at that isn't that a
gorgeous bird that's going to serve a
family of about 14 all coming apart some
people would say this is so
controversial what are you gonna do this
is the art of deconstructing the turkey
and then spats popping the breast very
important that's about to happen we're
about to do it
everybody's talking and everybody's
happy except the bird of course that's
the spatchcocking going on right now
oh yeah we don't need the breastbone
itself so we're gonna leave that out and
cook it but all the rest look it's
perfect oh that laughs now before I put
it in the oven we're talking about the
brine that I've been using here no
there's a humor aging debate amongst the
chef's community regarding brine do you
wet bright or do you dry bronze you know
why if you dry brine as I've done here
with a little time a little salt and
left it in the fridge overnight without
saran wrap on it
- maybe Chris fait extra space that's
the whole idea when you're getting this
going this way you're allowing the bird
to dry out a little bit making you
driver than the old wet brine days now
the wet brine days we're very very
everybody did it from the 40 50 60 s and
now this new on vole good dry brine
because you get a crispy er outside a
crispy your skin so this is now a turkey
that is a well not that attractive I'm
just being honest with you I think some
of the family when they get out the
Fantastico very fine wine later this is
a Chardonnay magnifique suspect you know
this is gonna be great with this Turkey
but the whole idea they were expecting
me to come out with the whole bird and
then use one of my ninja knives to carve
it not gonna happen I'm gonna be cutting
these and preparing these pieces in the
kitchen I'll present them beautifully as
you'll see later but it's not the same
thing now isn't worth it we don't know
because if they cook perfectly as I'm
suggesting this is going to work because
I'll check the breast temperature I'll
check the leg temperature the thigh the
wing I'll make sure it's all between 150
175 so it's perfectly cooked and I will
be removing the pieces as they're
perfectly cooked what you can't do if
the bird is whole so that's what you're
sacrificing presentation value versus a
perfectly cooked boule or turkey what
are the other I mean if you can get a
perfectly cooked bird what's wrong with
that and that's really what you're
trading off now if you can live with
bringing this out and all the kids going
oh where's the bird it's all chopped up
well and you can give them the best
turkey they've ever eaten that's the
trade-off well we're gonna find out I'm
gonna put this bird in the oven now off
the amount of work I've put in
can't tell you and you saw how it was
perfectly dismembered or deconstructed
as a more proper way to say at the
butcher but now it goes into the oven
are you ready
check it out perfectly brined dried out
in the fridge overnight ooh la la ah
chef wonderful taking big risk here with
the family oh that's hot yeah there we
go
spectacular now I'm gonna be monitoring
with the probe I'm gonna give it at
least remember got up to 400 degrees to
start dropping it down to 350 then I'll
be monitoring to get up to 150 and each
piece probing for that perfect
temperature then removing that part and
then letting it settle and then carving
we will see you soon is this gonna work
who knows we're gonna find out here now
this is the Mont of truth I have my
assistant Christine and her son Dylan
working with me now what is the
temperature of the breasts ladies and
gentlemen well let's test right now
because that's what matters
so use the probe because I have a
feeling that the breasts I will
absolutely do that for you cameraman
close up please because the breast looks
finished but the legs do not Christine
chop-chop-chop-chop let's go all right
so what we're going to be doing now is
separating the breast and leaving in the
other appendages because they're not
finished yet that is the whole idea of
deconstructing the bird this is the
total controversy we've lost the form
factor this looks like pool a pancake
it's not that exciting to look at and
certainly the family's not gonna be
excited about this because it's just
slabs of bone and flesh but will it be
spectacular bachelor to get separation
well I don't you terrific wait wait wait
here we go there we go very good so
that's the whole idea here what we're
doing is basically saying let's cook
them at different times to get the
perfect we get a close-up here cameraman
notice that these look undercooked the
breast looks ready that's what I'm
talking about
and
we're at it shouldn't I have a sip of
the fantastic O'Leary Cabernet 7 you
don't blend it with a little Merlot hmm
Oh save on you know you don't have to
have white wine with Turkey wow this is
really controversial Wow I can't believe
it everybody agrees yeah shocking
absolutely shocking think you've scored
something big I'm willing to endorse it
although my feelings are sort of a
traditional guy or romantic I feel sorry
for the bird it never gets to show
itself in its true form ever again but
the good news is we've got the O'Leary
fine wine whoa that really makes up for
the difference all right thank you
everybody let's chow down Gina wait
let's do another plug for the book this
book by Daymond John is called
powershift he wrote it while he was in
prison it's fantastic and lots of time
on his hands now he's out and he's
selling it buy this thing it's got every
one of his books the bestseller I have
to admit that's true no question that's
damn good advice Daymond and thank you
for it bye everybody really interesting
episode of ask mr. wonderful we'll see
you again next week
thanks Damon alright buddy what do you
want to do now